and Marianne Williamson joins us right
now how are you Marianne
okay thank you for having me are you
worried at all that
tick is a spy mechanism of the Communist
Chinese like so many have alleged
well I think that the surveillance for
many tech companies an issue whether
it's an American company or a Chinese
company it's certainly an issue uh if
you found out or if the top security
people in the country are telling you
that hey you're using a platform that
the Communist Chinese spy on us would
you take it seriously
well I'll tell you something Sean the
Chinese are spying on us in all kinds of
ways the truth of the matter is there
are many many millions of young people
if it's definitive I I understand that
but this is this is where young people
are getting their information and I
think that for us to deny that is kind
of ridiculous I think that whatever
regulations we have on Tick Tock
whatever the government decides to do
I'd like to see them be just as strong
uh in regulating American companies as
well so I'm looking at your numbers and
you know what 10 is not too shabby
that's a pretty that's a very
respectable number uh just like Robert F
Kennedy's number I think is at 21 is is
very respectable I think it speaks to
combined we're talking about 31 percent
of Democrats don't want Joe Biden that
speaks volumes uh so I started to do a
little deeper dive into your positions
and for example uh you seem to want to
eliminate all domestic energy production
or a lot of it in America and you said
that no phrase has been used more
manipulatively than National Security
um and you said our military madness has
not made us more secure it has made us
less secure
and I'm asking you to the extent that
you see China Russia Iran as National
Security threats and what would you have
done if you were president and the
Chinese spy balloon incident happened
and the Russia taking down of our drone
happened what would you do in those two
cases
well I I would I don't think that that
balloon should have gotten as far inland
as it got what would you be very clear
here well I think that that should have
probably been shot down over the water I
don't know why I was able to get as
close as it got into uh U.S territory I
agree with you once it was coming
through Alaska airspace I would have
shot that sucker right out of the sky
yeah yeah but let's be very clear what
would you have done with the drone
incident
are you talking about Syria where are
you talking about the dogs I'm talking
about the the Russians taking down one
of our drones
a Russian taking down one of our drones
where where are the you mean one of our
drones what country are you talking
about where they took down it was a high
profile incident that a Russian fighter
jet purposely hit and took down an
American drone out of the sky and Joe
Biden did nothing what would you have
done
it would depend on where the Drone was
you know we take down drones they take
down drones this is not the big picture
the big picture is how the U.S it
matters where it was when Russia is
going to take out one of our drones in
international airspace that's where it
was well you just said in international
airspace I don't know the case
I thought you knew the story okay so
what would you do you know the story is
well I'd have to I the story of the of
Russia is taking down a U.S spies a U.S
drone in international waters I wouldn't
what do you want me to do like commit
war against Russia because I took down a
U.S drone you have to be careful with
military matters you can't just go
around like you're a cowboy all the time
so if Russia takes down a U.S drone
listen we're dealing plenty with Russia
and in very important ways right now but
I think what's happening for instance
going on in Ukraine is far more
significant in terms of U.S involvement
with military matters in Russia then
they're taking down one drone I don't
know anymore about that do you believe
the U.S should have the meanest toughest
best military the greatest technology on
the face of the Earth for the cause of
Defending freedom because when you talk
about the phrase you know uh National
Security is used manipulatively
that sounds to me like you don't support
National Defense to the extent we have
you're you're absolutely well you're
absolutely incorrect of course United
States needs a strong military the way I
see military is Like a Surgeon if you
have to have surgery of you are
absolutely the United States needs to
have the best surgeon but a reasonable
person tries to avoid surgery if
necessary you know 60 Minutes recently
did an expose about the profound price
gouging of the defense contractors
towards the U.S military one of the
first things I would do as president is
to audit the Pentagon we know that we
have a bloated military budget we have
an 858 billion dollar military budget
and you know what Sean I do not believe
that the Iraq War made us more secure I
do not believe that staying at 20 years
longer than we needed to in Afghanistan
made us more secure we have to learn how
to wage peace Donald Trump okay how
would you say we need to learn I have a
test how would you wage peace and
prevent the Communist Chinese they have
stated their their territorial ambition
to take over Taiwan our Ally how would
you stage peace and prevent them from
taking over an innocent Sovereign Nation
one of the things that we need to do
with China is to be careful with the
language and we don't need to be in a
cold war with China and the last we
already need is war with China what do
you not answered you didn't answer my
question we need to step back this is an
important question what would you do if
they followed through on their
territorial ambition to take Taiwan or
Ally what would you do
I think that we need to do everything
possible to help make that not happen we
do not need American troops in Taiwan we
do not need to be in a war with China
I would agree with that now last
question you want to replace fossil
fuels what would you replace it with
today
there is tremendous green energy
possibilities winds solar there are so
many ways that we can compensate
to make the transition
quickly if we invest adequately you know
you said a few minutes ago that I wanted
to get rid of American energy production
no I don't I want to ramp down fossil
fuel energy Productions
up green energy production we need to
make a just transition from a dirty
energy to a clean energy grid how long
in your view would that take
well if you look at the money we spend
subsidizing the oil companies we could
take that same money and subsidize the
production of green energy we are
Americans we can do whatever we want and
if we decide that we're going to make a
massive transition a just transition to
a clean energy grid you absolutely can
believe it we have the money we have the
know-how we have the Ingenuity and we
have the spirit what we need is for
Americans to be mobilized and that is
what I promise you we cannot replace
fossil fuels in the next 20 to 30 years
impossible well we have to in order to
have a habitable planet
our planet is not fine right now
but you know
[Applause]
thank you for coming back we appreciate
the exchange thank you and
congratulations on your success hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else